based on the classic novel of the same
name the neverending story is treasured
by young and old fans alike decades
after its release the film continues to
resonate with audiences but there's more
to this timeless tale than you might
realize
here's the untold truth of the
neverending story Noah Hathaway brought
an entire gamut of emotions to his
portrayal of the young warrior Atreyu
from his intense vulnerability as he
mourns the loss of his horse
artax to his fierceness and battle
against the evil Gomorrah it's hard to
imagine the film with anyone but
Hathaway in the role however his journey
to being cast was nearly as arduous as
his character's journey in the movie
talking to Entertainment Weekly for the
film's 35th anniversary Hathaway
revealed that he was among 50,000
hopefuls from around the world who
auditioned for the part of the strong
and sensitive
Atreyu when he was finally cast the
film's original director ended up
leaving the project opening the door for
Wolfgang Petersen to take over which
meant that Hathaway had to begin the
audition process all over again
in total Hathaway recalls auditioning at
least 10 times but in the end he
survived the casting process and finally
became a Trejo
[Music]
No
while Hathaway began acting long before
the neverending story
afterward he only had a few more
on-screen appearances before mostly
retiring Hathaway has also worked as a
tattoo artist and of course he was asked
to do a lot of tattoos inspired by the
neverending story as if the scene with
Atreyu and art acts and the swamps of
sadness isn't traumatic enough there was
a horrible urban legend that the real
horse didn't survive the film shoot what
don't worry
that story is completely untrue after
filming the production even gave
Hathaway one of the horses from the film
as well as the saddle for all his hard
work unfortunately it was too
complicated to ship an animal
internationally Hathaway ended up giving
the horse to his riding double
luckily the horse went on to live for
another 20 years in Germany Hathaway
continues to joke that he feels
responsible for so many people's
childhood trauma because of that
heartbreaking scene with artax Hathaway
has also mentioned that he feels like
he's giving fans a little therapy when
he meets them at his convention
appearances while no horses were hurt
during the many difficult days of
shooting the movie the same can't be
said for Hathaway
even before primary filming began one of
the horses fell on him and he ended up
with a broken back he was in traction
for an entire month and they weren't
sure if he would be healed in time to
actually play a Trejo after everything
he'd been through to land the part
losing it before even beginning would
have been heartbreaking
luckily Hathaway healed up quickly even
though he would be injured a few more
times while working on the set in
particular during the swamps of sadness
seen when a Trejo is face-to-face with
Morla the ancient one those scenes took
the production to grueling months to
film and saw Hathaway constantly soaking
wet and covered in muck for much of the
time because of his initial accident
with the horse Hathaway has titanium
screws in his spine and still has to
deal with painful back issues the
neverending story is filled with
fantastical characters who are brought
to life using practical special effects
and puppetry and as hard as it is to
conceive of the movie without Hathaway
as a Trejo
it's almost weirder to find out that the
voices of the kindly Falk or the
limestone loving rockbiter and the
menacing Gamora were all provided by the
same person after primary filming was
finished veteran character and voice
actor Alan Oppenheimer who was also
featured in such iconic shows
he-man the Smurfs and transformers was
first approached by peterson to do the
voice of Falk or Oppenheimer flew to
Germany and did his work but wasn't
happy with his first attempt as the
voice of the luckdragon
he went back for a second pass at fall
Corps and in the process
Oppenheimer completely fell in love with
the movie since Peterson had yet to find
appropriate voices for the rock fighter
and Kimura he had Oppenheimer give it a
shot
the result was three distinct characters
that you'd never guess were all voiced
by the same person on top of that
Oppenheimer
also ended up performing the voice of
the narrator we can't help but wonder
how Petersen was able to find one actor
who could contribute so much to the film
mm-hmm with look plenty of fans of the
movie have imagined what it would be
like to ride Falkor through the skies of
Fantasia or on earth chasing down some
bullies but for Hathaway the experience
left something to be desired
Falkor was actually a huge contraption
that at times was suspended 20 feet in
the air and required a minimum of 15
people to operate pathaway told
Entertainment Weekly riding Falkor
wasn't as glamorous as you might imagine
sometimes it would overheat and it would
start going out of control probably once
every 20 minutes it ended up being like
riding a bucking bronco I just had to
hold on for dear life from time to time
but it was fun in the same Entertainment
Weekly interview Petersen pinpointed a
major reason the film still resonates so
deeply even in the age of HD it took a
lot of work to have it come out the way
it did on film and I believe that's what
gives this movie such a great quality
that can be appreciated after all these
years the creatures were so real how
they had to interact with the actors it
wasn't like they were just standing in
front of this green screen and
pretending and for those who still dream
of riding Falkor you can visit him at
bavaria film studios in germany where
the actual luckdragon from the film is
part of an exhibit that's open to the
public even the most devoted neverending
story fan might not know that there are
essentially two different versions of
the soundtrack out in the world the
German version was fully scored by Klaus
doll dinger but s Petersen considered
his vision going international he
brought in songwriter and composer
Giorgio Moroder to add some final
flourishes to the score that North
Americans are most familiar with another
huge difference is that the German
version of the movie doesn't have the
famous beer worm of a theme song sung by
pop star Lomov the song ended up being a
hit
but it almost wasn't included in the
film because the then president of EMI
records absolutely hated it
however because moroder was so impressed
with lamal after meeting him he showed
support for the singer and the tune
ended up opening the movie in a huge way
the song had a major resurgence in 2019
when it was featured in an episode of
stranger things and after listening to
Dusty bun and Suzy Pudu at the iconic
tune over and over again fans kept
coming back to the same thought and want
to hear it not right now yes now Dusty
bun unlike many of its contemporaries
the neverending story has aged really
well one of the reasons is because
Peterson was an absolute perfectionist
consistently requiring multiple takes in
order to get every scene exactly right
speaking to the News Tribune Hathaway
noted that a three-month filming
schedule ended up turning into a whole
year because Peterson kept requiring
take after take however eagle-eyed
viewers of the film might notice that
some of the actors in the English
version appear to be dubbed this is
because many of them were German and
didn't speak English at all they read
their lines in German and American voice
actors were brought in later to
re-record English versions of their
scenes the terrifying threat to Fantasia
and the human world as well was a
dreadful void called the nothing
well according to gue Mork the nothing
is an emptiness or despair fueled by the
loss of hopes and dreams that nothing
was an esoteric threat but also very
real in the world of the neverending
story talking to sci-fi now the movie
special effects coordinator Brian
Johnson explained that he conceptualized
the nothing in the movie by essentially
using the horizon as a starting point
then showing the natural world
disintegrating and disappearing into it
this was one of the few moments when
camera tricks were utilized the
nothing's unique effects are depicted as
colors splashed across the sky while the
illusion of nothingness takes center
stage Peterson was no stranger to
critically acclaimed films however he
wasn't familiar with making an
english-language movie that would
connect with english-speaking audiences
through his film das boat Peterson
became friends with Steven Spielberg and
they often chatted about filmmaking over
the phone when Spielberg was in the
early stages of planning Schindler's
List Peterson helped him Scout different
locations for filming in return
Spielberg was more than happy to take a
look at Peterson's working version of
the neverending story and he helped cut
some foot
that he felt would paste the movie
better for international audiences in
particular North Americans Peterson has
said that Spielberg admitted he learned
those tips from George Lucas who helped
him develop his own sense of pacing
because of Spielberg's edits the
American version of the movie is seven
minutes shorter than the German one as
thanks for his notes and kindness
Peterson gave Spielberg one of the most
coveted props from the film the Orang
necklace that Atreyu where's Spielberg
still has the Orang to this day mikail n
does the neverending story was a global
bestseller after its 1979 publication
when the books rights were sold for the
film adaptation Peterson was supposed to
write the script for Enda himself but
this is where problems with the
production began Enda didn't understand
why his enormous story would need to be
altered in order to fit a two-hour
running time Peterson said the story was
so sacred to Enda that it made
collaborating with him extremely
difficult so Peterson ended up
co-writing the script with Herman Wagle
instead when Peterson sent over the
final draft Enda was so furious at how
it turned out that he tried to sue to
have production stopped the movie came
out anyway and unsurprisingly and I
hated it in fact he had some especially
scathing things to say about the first
gate that Atreyu passed on his way to
the southern Oracle the Sphinx's are
quite one of the biggest embarrassments
of the film they are full bosom
strippers who sit there in the desert
Enda also called the film disgusting and
even went so far as to accuse the
production of ruining his story just for
the money claiming they didn't
understand the core themes of the book
because of Enders absolute hatred of the
movie Petersen said that the rights to
the story are tied up in litigation with
no end in sight basically don't expect a
remake anytime soon Petersen is
completely okay with that and the film
he directed he told Entertainment Weekly
it is my understanding that some films
you should leave alone and that's how I
feel about this film I like the way the
film is with all its old-fashioned charm
another person who has some thoughts on
the possibility of a remake is the
childlike Empress herself Tammy Stroh
neck while Stroh neck has admitted she
would enjoy watching a remake she also
had a very positive perspective on the
message of the existing movie I think
the film is an invitation to grow the
space of making and creating hopefully
if Hollywood diversifies and there are
more women directors and more minorities
writing scripts the message of the film
will be the ultimate winner here so I
don't think when
to remake this but I think we need to
keep growing the space for everyone
ultimately a remake seems unnecessary
since the original film has more than
stood the test of time and if fans truly
want to experience more of Fantasia they
can take bastions lead find a secluded
spot and read the original neverending
story check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about classic movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]